All right. Welcome. Welcome. What's popping.
Now today we have a special guest. We have John Kim. Hey guys.
He actually also has a YouTube channel. It's called Solon encoded.
So you guys should check that out. He has a lot of good insights. Now,
the reason why I have him today is because he has a very special case.
He did not come from a CS background. He, I don't even have a CS degree. No,
he does not. But where do you work? I work at capital one, capital one.
As a software engineer. Software engineer. Yeah. I just got senior too.
So that's pretty nice. Yeah.
Yeah. I ha I have never gone senior yet, but yeah. So as you can see,
it's very possible to get a software engineering job without a
degree. So we're going to be talking about that.
All right. So before we start,
I just want to ask like a few questions just to determine what kind of engineer
you are. So first question Mac or PC. Both.
You can't choose both.
I have both. I use both at work. Do you use Mac? Because they gave me a Mac.
I thought it would be the opposite.
I thought you would use Mac personally and then PCs.
No capital. One's pretty Hitman. Wholly. When I worked for Citadel,
they gave me windows. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So what about home? You use windows.
I use both, but windows for gaming for, you know,
like got it. Everything else development. Yeah.
That makes sense. Windows for interesting spaces or cabs?
Tabs. Okay. What's your favorite ID?
I like, I like a lot. I like Adam right now.
Yeah. That's good. That's good. Do you use like any special plugins or like.
Yeah, I have tons. Like I try to not go too crazy.
Yeah. I don't want to get too cluttered.
Yeah. There's like one where like,
like it's like a number that pops up every time you talk.
About languages, your favorite language.
I like JavaScript right now. Web people like to hate it.
Did I love JavaScript? I loved,
I let them know Jess my jam and also Google with the VA engine. Yeah.
It's amazing. Cool. All right.
So I guess now we're just going to go over more kind of like a personal
question, just to get to know you better. So as a kid, I mean,
I'm guessing maybe you didn't know much about engineering and stuff like that,
but did you have any affinity to building things?
Yeah. I mean, Lego was my thing for awhile,
but I actually just really liked video games. That was like my thing, like, I,
I hated studying. I hate, I just like,
I like making stuff into video games and uh, yeah, my dad was an engineer,
so I kind of had that like drilled in me, like making stuff.
Cool. I got two important questions. Okay. First question.
Which games do you play? Superstar?
That was like my thing. Millie?
Yeah, no, seriously.
I played a sheep. man. Yeah, I played Martin. Okay.
She gives you usually like Sheik would have an advantage against Mark. Really?
I didn't get that.
Like into it too. I mean, I played, I played a lot. Like,
did you ever go to competition and stuff? No. I mean,
my parents wouldn't lend me, you know, they thought did you know how to use,
like wait dash dash. I did a little bit of weight.
Okay. What about the second question? So you worked for capital one now,
do you like enjoy your job?
Yeah, no, I love my job, actually.
My bosses are really good and capital one is really good perks.
So a lot of people don't know this because cabaret lens is more East coast
company, but they're huge. They have like crazy campuses.
It's not like a boring or a bank.
Recently. Yeah. The reason why I ask is because you love video games, right?
Yeah. So I was worrying like,
do you ever think about moving into game development? Ah.
So the thing is I have a few friends who are in games and then their number one
tip is to knock it into gear.
If you like video. Yeah. That's all I heard. Yeah.
Like when you work for gaming, it's actually.
James you yeah.
And video game programming is probably one of the hardest to do and
time-consuming to do just assuming, just to make it a little guy to move.
It takes you like.
Yeah, that makes sense. So maybe no plans to go with gaming.
And the money's in, um.
Like apps, to be honest,
the money's in like web and cool. Cool.
So what about on your free time? Like what do you do nowadays? Like.
I have a BA I have a newborn, so yeah. Look so young though,
but I'm married, so, Oh, wow. It's uh, yeah, it's,
that's takes up a lot of time. I like to make YouTube videos,
but I actually like really enjoy programming and I'm like kind of
lucky that I get to do that for them.
Yeah. All right. So I guess before we start, um, I should have one question.
So what did you do in college?
So I actually just studied economics and accounting.
Yeah. So what did you want to do before college?
Like did you want to be an economist? Is that even with.
No, actually my,
my dad's an engineer and he's always pushed me to be an engineer,
but I was pretty bad school. So rebel. Yeah, I got it.
I got it. Okay. So you did economics and then what'd you end up with,
did you do internships or anything?
I did. I did like zero internships. So I should have brought,
I should have watched videos, man. Hey, at all,
even though you were feeling like I was probably like playing StarCraft or
something probably less good. That's pretty much what I did.
Makes sense. Makes sense. But yeah. Um, so that's the thing.
So you did economics and then you didn't do any internships.
And then did you land a job right after you got.
No, actually I did it.
So it was like 2010 right after the financial crisis.
So it was really tough. The market was pretty tough, so. Okay.
So I ended up going back to school for this cat program.
It's like this isn't Santa Clara. It's like a,
I want to say like eight months program where you get all the classes for
accounting essentially.
Okay. And then you got accounting.
Jobs? Yeah. And then I got my accounting. Um,
so I had like interviews and like ENY and like the befores by pretty good.
I mean, I have a lot of friends.
Who want.
To end up with those
[inaudible] come on, man.
I ended up working at a small Korean firm. It was terrible.
Oh, nice. Okay, cool.
So then when did you start knowing about coding or did you knew before,
but you just didn't get into it.
It was actually during that time, my, um, friends and I,
we kind of got together were just tinkering. I,
it was like my roommate and another friend who, uh, came, just got back.
He was like studying,
he was unemployed at the time he just started tinkering and I actually started
doing art instead.
Okay. So you guys were making an app and you were doing like sidebar?
Yeah. Yeah. I did like design. I made like, you know,
like circles and squares and stuff. And then.
You start wanting to code. Is that how it happened?
It actually, it came out of necessity. Necessity, I guess. Yeah.
Cause they found jobs as engineers essentially.
And then I went back to San Jose and then I was like,
I have all these art skills, but I still want to make like apps.
So that's when I started. Yeah.
Uh, if you don't mind me asking, what was the app about.
This is video games.
We made this like hamster it's actually really embarrassing.
So I'll probably I'll find some clips of it. And I'll show you.
Was it like a cute game or was it like a.
It was a cute game kickings or.
Yeah. And so when, so, okay.
What was your first development job and how'd you get?
Well,
actually my first development actual job would be this current one that I
have. Yeah. I knew the CEO in Korea who had a small app company.
So I did some stuff with it and I called that my internship. So connections.
Connections, connections are pretty important.
To grind and hustle and you know, that's all that matters.
Yeah, Indiana.
I just want to talk about how important connections are because yes.
I talk about internships and all of that, but in the end,
the reason like all these internship was because of connections and that
connection for me is U Waterloo. You know,
because they're known to produce like a high quality engineers and then that's
why they hire us. So Indiana connections are really important. Uh,
I hate the word networking,
but I do think that's one of the most valuable skill you can have. I agree.
And sometimes not going to lie. It's about luck. If you happen to know someone,
for example, I happened to know my brother and he happened to be, you know,
he paved the way for me, so yeah.
So how did you even get those, uh, capital ones? So you got a few internships,
like with the Korean CEO and then w what else was there.
And your resume? So I, I like self study on and off for like three years.
I tried like iOS and Java, but, um, I ended up going to a bootcamp actually.
So that was probably the biggest like boost,
but the bootcamp itself doesn't really help you in terms of boosting your
resume. Actually it's, uh, sometimes it's considered a negative,
like there's like people looking for like new bootcamp applications. Right.
Um, but I did a lot of projects in hackathons when I was at the bootcamp.
Okay. So, um, what, what was that about?
You can't call it, it's called, um, uh, Def bootcamp.
Okay. And, uh, how much, how much should it cost? So.
The total was like 13,000, I believe, maybe 15,000.
I forget exactly. But it was, it was pretty hefty. It was a decent amount.
Luckily I had, yeah.
I guess like, how did you choose a bootcamp?
Cause now there are so many and some people think some of them are scams.
Some of them are not sure how, how, like, why this one? So.
It kind of goes back to connections. Um, I did. Uh, so when,
during my whole time in like investigating about programming,
I started a podcast where I like interviewed software engineers and there was
this one guy who I interview, he went to hack reactor,
and he was telling me about his experience.
And he was actually an accountant to go into a hacker, uh, engineer.
So he gave me a lot of information and, um,
he told me like the ones that are good right now, I will say,
cause my boot kit no longer exists. Um,
but I would say hack reactor and app Academy is probably the best. Um,
there's a few other good ones, but you gotta watch out. Right.
So on your resume, basically, you had a few internships and then the bootcamp.
Right. And then that's when you applied to capital one.
Yeah, pretty much. So actually I didn't, I never applied,
I met someone there at a meetup. So again,
like all my interviews I ever got after my bootcamp, um,
was because I met people. I reached out.
Got it.
Okay. So did you interview for them or did you just get the job?
We have a pretty stringent interview process, like any fortune 500 com. Got it.
But, um, the initial like interview, like I didn't have to go through a parser,
which my, I don't think my resume would have through,
cause I don't have Waterloo.
Because I went to Waterloo.
Yeah. I guess that's one thing I want to mention too.
Like a lot of people ask me like, Oh,
is it important to get a CS degree and stuff like that?
And I say like for the skills, maybe not, you know,
for the actual work experience, maybe not.
But the reason is because they have so many applicants that the only way they
can go through all the applicants is by filtering people out and like for them,
yes. They know that they might filter out really talented people. If, you know,
sometimes they don't have a CS degree, but they're still very talented,
but it's just, you know, the opportunity costs of going through all of them.
It's just too high for them, you know? So it's like, I understand that it's,
but it's just a limitation.
We don't have enough resources to go through all of them.
So your way to standing out is to have these stupid keyboards like Ivy league.
But yeah, it sucks,
but I think that's why trying to get the connection or like a referral,
you know, it's really important. Yeah.
The referrals are like super important. Um,
I found work like a month after my bootcamp and that's on the very fast side.
Most of my friends, they took six to year, six months a year. Wow.
So that's something they leave out at bootcamps. I see, you know, 99,
95% success rate, but maybe a year later.
So capital one, when you just started, did you with people who had CS degrees?
Are they like you who didn't have CS?
A good mix of both actually. Yeah. Um, and surprisingly,
I would say the people who went to bootcamps were in a sense,
like more like driven. Okay. Yeah. It's kind of interesting how that is.
Yeah.
I felt that a lot, uh, at my other jobs too,
because you feel like you need to prove yourself.
Exactly. Now that's imposter syndrome.
Exactly. So can you talk more about imposter syndrome? Like, did you have it?
I did for a little bit, like how long? Um, maybe like three months,
like, um, I always say it takes like three months to get used to a job.
Makes sense. Yeah. Maybe it was like a job in the good new job thing,
but it was like totally different for me. New job, big company career switch,
all this stuff. So.
So like, uh, like what were you most afraid of that you thought you didn't know.
To put it? Simply asking dumb questions. Okay. You know?
Cause like you don't know what you don't know. That's true. So it's like,
I didn't, like I had questions about JIRA. Right. Stupid. Okay.
Yeah. Um, yeah. Asking you about dumb questions is interesting because, um,
a lot of people say like, Oh, don't be afraid to ask questions.
There's no such thing as dumb questions. Yeah. Maybe that's true.
Like maybe for score something that, but when your reputation is on the line,
when your job is on the line, when you have people looking at you,
working with you,
sometimes their judgment can lead to like future repercussions. Right.
And maybe internships, not that bad because you're going to leave anyways.
But when it's a full-time job, it's a lot harder.
I was lucky that I did a lot of internships.
So I'd ask all the stupid questions there. So if ever you do an internship,
make sure to ask a stupid question then now when you're full full-time yeah.
For example, I asked what LS was in the terminal, you know,
it's to look at your file system. Yeah. Stuff like that.
And then the guy just looked at me, he's like, dude, what the are you? You know?
But here's the thing, like, you know, you don't know, you know.
So you don't know. Right. Exactly.
So, yeah. So it is kind of a tricky thing, especially at full-time. So I don't,
I don't, I'm not going to say, Oh, you should just ask the question, you know,
but yeah. Cool. So what about, um,
do you have any like tips and tricks to stand out? I mean like first of all,
I guess some people would probably even look down on you because you came from
bootcamp. So how do you prove to them that like, no, I'm good.
So there's, there's a few ways and everyone has like different opinions.
What I do is I want a bunch of, I just want a bunch of hackathons that yeah.
Can we talk about hackathon? Like what was it?
So let's see.
So I won one of the sponsor prizes from tech crunch disrupt.
That's like probably the largest hackathon. And then there was a few other ones,
one at Facebook called chime hack. Um, that was really fun.
That was my pretty big names. Surprise. Yeah. Yeah.
There was a small one where it was like hack against violence.
So it was like some, yeah, that one was like.
Okay. So can you tell me about one, like, I guess the best one,
the one that you want or like the one that you felt like you did the most work
or that you learned the most? Can you talk about that hackathon?
Sure. Um, actually the Facebook one was the number,
like probably the life changing moment.
Cause that was the first one that I want. And, um,
it was literally right after I learned about like restful services.
Can we just built the credit credit at the Facebook? And we won based on that.
Wow.
Like that really changed my mind that like I thought hackathons were for these
like nerdy, like super like, you know.
It's not, yeah. It's not in line most of the times when I go to hackathons,
they're all like full knees. Yeah. No,
I honestly hate that because they just spit out like all these technologies that
they don't know how to use just to just like sound smart stuff.
Imposter syndrome. Yeah. But yeah. So, okay. So you made a crude up, like what,
what did it do? Like.
So that was basically it,
the whole theme was to report like sexual abuse. So we made, uh,
an app where basically people who are like
consultants and like people who have like skills to help people who, you know,
got traumatized.
Like they could connect on one side and like they could be on their messenger or
whatever. And then the other, like people who actually needed help,
they could go in and it was like kind of connecting them on the honestly got it.
Yeah. That's actually a really cool cause. Like I like to tell people a lot, um,
about making apps, you know, like it's not about the latest technology.
It's not about how good your technology is, especially because I kind of, uh,
I'm leaving on the product side now I care about, you know,
does your product add value to a person's life? Yeah.
Building a simple rest API by having tremendous value to it. For example,
you know, the app that you make is a lot more important than using all the fancy
technology.
No, that's true. And then most of the judges, they don't care. Exactly know.
They just want to know they just want a good presentation and that good picture,
you know, so yeah.
That's it cool. Uh, so what about like the interview for capital one?
How'd you prepare for that?
So, you know, standard cracking the coding interviews. Um,
I went to like meetups where they did an interview preps.
I talked to some of my other bootcamp grads.
We kinda got together and like asked each other questions,
like lots and lots of HackerRank problems.
So when you actually did the interview,
did you feel prepared because of the cracking decoding interviews?
Yeah,
definitely cracking like that book is probably the Holy
grail of like programming and every questions is great.
So what's the percentage of like technical questions and like non-technical
questions. And do you think those matter?
So for capital one, um, they made me do a take home.
So I created a react app where like I listed like once a bank tracks,
transactions and stuff. And then they had like four people interview me.
So there was two like three technical interviews.
So they asked me like a lot of technical questions. I did some white boarding.
Um, and then we have one behavior questions. Cool.
Cool. Nice. Okay. So a lot of those traditional coding.
Yeah. Traditional, like I'm not sure exactly the percentage,
but it was a lot of coding. Yeah.
Cool. All right. So back to personal life, um, yeah. How old is your kid now?
Yeah, my kids like, uh, three months, he just had his hundred day, man.
It's crazy. They're going like this.
Are you going to, is it a he or she is, are you going to make him a programmer?
Yeah, I am actually, well, I mean, who knows.
What they're going to grow up to revise. Okay. Parenting,
are we going to change into a parenting channel now? But yeah.
So question how,
like I always thought that parents always try to raise their kids in ways that
they've never been raised before, you know,
because they kind of want to either one that vicariously through their kids or
to have their kids live the life they couldn't have. Do you think that's true?
Are you going to do that?
I had a really good childhood, so I love my parents. I still like,
we're kind of lucky in a sense where I know a lot of people don't like speak to
their parents often and once they grow up and have their own family,
but we talk like every day.
So I want to try to encourage them to do like, kind of raised them similarly,
but there's different things. Like they're really strict on school and I,
I'm not a school guy, so I want to,
I just want them to be passionate about something. I don't care what it is.
Like I say programming.
Yeah. I guess that makes sense. Cause like for my parents,
I think the reason why they were probably stricter on school was because they
don't want me to end up like them where they don't have like good jobs and stuff
like that. So they want me to just be decently wealthy, to live a normal life.
And then for me, imagine if I had a kid in my mind, what I would do is like, Oh,
I have a decent living.
It's okay if they fail at school because I want them to live the life I can
have, which is, you know, to express your artistic freedom, you know,
to do more art classes because I didn't do that much. Sure. You know,
and there were a lot of sports I wanted to do,
but we just didn't have the money to do it. So I think if I had a kid,
I would be like, yo man, like guitar and do that. But I think he would be like,
you're. Yeah. I don't want to do any pushing me. I just want to good in school,
but yeah, you gotta find yourself, find yourself, dude, go through YouTube,
go fly that. There's no travel, travel on it. No,
I just want to go to Stanford and study, but yeah. Cool. Nice.
So I guess, um, yeah. Uh, thank you so, so much for coming in and uh, yeah.
Things are very invaluable. Yeah. You wanna, you know,
plug your channel and film.
Yeah, I got it. Um, yeah. So my name is John, as I mentioned, um,
you guys can check me out at Solon coated,
like for everything like Instagram and YouTube.
I do a lot of like programming related, like, you know,
lecture type videos and a little bit of like logging type videos.
So come check me out.
I think that's about it. And thank you for watching. See you guys next time,
please.